hey guys it's Jonah here do you wish
that you can just eat and eat and still
remain slim without having to worry
about what goes into your mouth well
almost all foods contain calories some
foods are more calorie dense compared to
others some foods have so few calories
they aren't worth counting we call them
free foods so if you're still learning
about portion control counting calories
and changing your eating habits I think
that it is very important to keep a food
journal to know what and how much you
have eaten but let's face it counting
every single calorie can be a nightmare
and it shouldn't be an obsession so I
want to share with you a list of three
foods that you can eat without going
crazy about tracking them first leafy
greens you can literally eat as much
leafy greens as you want and never gain
weight for instance one cup of spinach
only has seven calories and it is packed
with nutrients other examples include
arugula platters romaine spinach
watercress kale collard greens bok choy
and Swiss chard darker color leafy
greens tend to be more nutrient rich
compared to the lighter varieties so
stack a plate with lots of leafy greens
and consume at least one cup every day
next high volume vegetables vegetables
which are high in water and fiber can
fill you up on very few calories
examples include old iffy greens
asparagus broccoli beetroot cabbage
carrots celery cucumber zucchini and
bell pepper so you get a larger portion
with very few calories high volume
fruits generally all fruits are good for
you but not all fruits are low in
calories and they should be consumed in
moderation free fruits are high in water
content and should be included into your
diet more frequently examples include
lime lemon orange grapefruit tomato
apricot peach strawberry blueberry
watermelon and
you so you can have them as your snack
blend them to make smoothies or even
make flavored water next broth broth is
the ultimate high volume food so one cup
of homemade chicken broth only has 18
calories I like to make soup noodles and
toss in lots of vegetables and also lean
protein it is a great low calorie meal
that is very filling if you were to buy
packaged broth be aware of the sodium
content go for low sodium or sodium free
broth and use it in moderation next
herbs and spices this is the secret
weapon to pack in the flavors and also
nutrients without damaging your waist
line one teaspoon of dried spice
typically has about nine calories and
one cup of fresh herbs contains only
four calories do you know that one
tablespoon of basil has the same amount
of antioxidants as two cups of grapes
and one teaspoon of cinnamon has as many
antioxidants as half a cup of
blueberries so the next time you cook
spice it up with turmeric cinnamon
ginger cloves paprika and toss in lots
of herbs such as stage oregano basil
coriander times two packing all the good
stuff next condiments choosing the right
condiments is crucial to not ruin your
weight loss progress a healthy meal can
be ruined by high-fat high-calorie dips
such as mayonnaise or ranch dressing so
the baseline to stick by is to choose
condiments which has less than 20
calories per tablespoon some healthier
examples include
sabi vinegar horseradish tzatziki
mustard hot sauce or salsa again a lot
of store-bought condiments tend to be
high in sodium and sugar so be sure to
read the food labels and make smarter
choices pickles
despite the different cultures we have
been preserving food for centuries
through pickling pickles can be part of
a healthy diet it is high in probiotics
and also antioxidants which is also
great for our digestion
so generally pickles are low in fat and
calories but very
high in sodium a dill pickle spear only
has poor calories and one gram of fat
but 306 milligrams of sodium which is
about 13% of the daily recommendation
you don't have to give up pickles but
have them in small amounts just to
flavor your food if possible choose the
low-sodium varieties or even better
pickle your own vegetables so the next
category to look at is our drinks if
you're not aware of it liquid calories
can very easily add up to your waistline
and also ruin your fitness progress so I
would encourage you to limit high liquid
calories because most of the time they
tend to be empty calories with no
nutrients on the other hand there are
free drinks which you can consume on a
daily basis such as water sparkling
water black coffee black tea herbal tea
or homemade flavor water finally treats
if you want to treat yourself and still
watch your weight stay away from high
fat calorie dense cakes pastries or ice
cream go for sugar-free jell-o or even
popcorn so one cup of air-popped popcorn
only has 31 calories and can make a very
healthy snack however if you were to
consume the entire bag you will be
consuming almost 200 calories so
remember that portion control is still
very important all these free foods will
fill you up on very little calories and
the great thing is you don't have to
keep track of every single calorie
saying that however I'm not suggesting
that you should only be sticking to
eating free foods there are still a lot
of healthy calorie dense food that you
should consume in moderation such as
avocado olive oil nuts seeds oily fish
and also dried fruits so the key is to
find the right balance and enjoy a huge
variety of foods if you like this video
if you enjoy this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up share it and subscribe to
my youtube channel for new weekly videos
do also check out more video links in my
description box for more tips on healthy
eating all the best
you
you
you